[Applaus]
[Musik]
Argentinien wurde Weltmeister Messi zum
endgültigen Fußballgott und die deutsche
Mannschaft hat sich den Mund zugehalten
das etwa wird wohl in Erinnerung bleiben
von der Fußball-WM 2022 in Katar wenn
die Deutschen doch wenigstens so gut
gespielt hätten wie sie in Sachen
politischer Gesten auffielen aber
unabhängig davon wie man das ganze
bewertet also das Theater um die
korrekte Kapitänsbinde und die Gesten
auf die Mannschaftsfoto es hatte ja
einen Grund man wollte auf die Lage der
Menschenrechte in Katara Hinweisen eine
sehr wichtige Sache denn um diese Rechte
steht ist nun mal nicht gut in dem Land
die Missstände existieren ganz egal ob
diejenigen die darauf hinweisen nun
reiche Fußballer aus dem Westen sind
oder nicht nicht umsonst nannten viele
Kritiker diese WM auch die
Weltmeisterschaft der Schande
schließlich wurde das Turnier in einem
autoritären Land ausgetragen Demokratie
gibt es dort nicht Menschenrechte auch
nicht zumindest keine Nacht westlichen
Verständnis in Katar basiert das Gesetz
auf der Scharia dem islamischen Recht so
ist zum Beispiel Homosexualität verboten
und wird sogar verfolgt klar dass unter
solchen Umständen viele Diskussionen um
dieses Thema die WM begleitet haben aber
ebenso stand eine andere Sache im
Zusammenhang mit dem Turnier die extrem
miese Lage von Arbeitsmigranten wobei
hier das Wort Sklaven wo die bessere
Bezeichnung wäre die Kritik an der WM
richtete sich im Übrigen nicht nur gegen
Katara sie richtete sich auch gegen
Fußballverbände Funktionäre und
Mannschaften kurz gegen die Welt des
Fußballs schließlich handelt es sich um
eine Welt die oft oberflächlich
politisch und moralisch korrekt Auftritt
aber trotzdem mit genau denen Geschäfte
macht die Menschenrechte mit Füßen
treten und die Lage der Menschenrechte
in Katar war auch schon schlecht als die
Spieler des FC Barcelona folgendes
Trikot Drogen schon als der FC Barcelona
2015 die Champions League gewonnen
flossen 10 Millionen petrol oder was aus
Katar in die Vereinskasse und die
Gehälter von Messi Neymar und Co zu
bezahlen zu dieser Zeit herrschte in
Katar noch immer das Sklaven Regime oder
wie man ist doch nett die Falle ab und
das ist noch nicht alles denn auch in
anderen Ländern gibt es dieses System
wird man einen Blick auf diese Karte
es gibt noch sieben weitere Länder die
die kafal am Meer oder weniger stark
nutzen Saudi-Arabien die Vereinigten
Arabischen Emirate dort Dahlien Kuwait
Libanon und Oman und in all diesen
Ländern ist die Lage der
Arbeitsmigranten ähnliche wie in Katara
darüber hinaus sind an diesem System
auch länderbeteiligt die einem auf den
ersten Blick nicht einfallen zum
Beispiel Uganda wie das alles
zusammenhängt erklären wir noch später
im Video die Wahrheit ist aber auch das
ist viel Halbwissen rund um die Verfall
ergibt vielleicht haben viele von euch
er Schlagzeilen im Kopf über
Arbeitsmigranten die auf Baustellen der
WM in Katar ums Leben gekommen sind hier
das Beispiel vom Guardian aufgedeckt
seit der Vergabe der Weltmeisterschaft
starben in Katar 6.500 Arbeitsmigranten
dieser Bericht hat damals so einige
Wellen geschlagen und jeder Leser
brachte es wohl mit den schlechten
Bedingungen auf den Baustellen der WM
Stadien in Verbindung aber stellt sich
die vielleicht dringende Frage handelt
es sich hier um viele Tote wenn man
sollte berücksichtigen das
arbeitsmanganten nicht nur auf den
wm-baustellen gearbeitet haben viel mehr
sind sie in allen Branchen tätig als
Hausangestellte oder Fahrer kurz gesagt
alle Arten von Servicepersonal
bei den Toten handelt es sich außerdem
keineswegs nur um Arbeitsunfälle sondern
alle möglichen Todesfälle die nun mal
vorkommen können die Schlagzeile des
garantieren
zumindest haben einige Menschen etwas
genauer auf die Zahlen geschaut was er
eigentlich die Aufgabe der Journalisten
gewesen wäre also seht euch mal an was
stattdessen dr Andreas Krieg vom Kings
College London zu den Zahlen sagen
ursprünglichen Bericht des Guardian war
die Rede von 6.500 todesfällt innerhalb
von 10 Jahren bei rund 1,4 Millionen
Arbeitsmigranten in Deutschland sterben
pro Million junge Männer unter 25 Jahren
jedes Jahr 560 also 5.600 in 10 Jahren
so gesehen ist die Zahl natürlich nicht
zu bemerkenswert und der Herr ist
Experte für den anderen Osten und für
Sicherheitspolitik also alles doch nicht
so schlimm nun ja Katar ist dennoch
keine Arbeiterparadies Missstände gibt
es dort zu Hause für uns zumindest ist
dieser Widerspruch einen Grund genauer
hin zu schauen und jede Dinge zu
beleuchten die etablierte Medien kaum
oder nur am Rande berichten die Fragen
lauten also was eigentlich ist die
Kavala und wie funktioniert sie woher
bekommen diese Länder am Persischen Golf
ihre Arbeitskräfte hat die
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft wirklich dazu
beigetragen Reformen in Katar
voranzutreiben wie die FIFA behauptet
hat heute werden wir all diese Fragen
beantworten und zwar gleich nach einem
kleinen werbehindert unsere Sponsors
nordpass nordpass ist ein Tool mit dem
ihr eure Passwörter sicher aufbewahren
können egal ob es um Website Anwendungen
oder Kreditkarten geht mit nordpass
kannst du automatisch sichere Passwörter
für jedes deiner Kunden erstellen und
sie in eine Port speichern ohne dass du
sie dir merken musst dadurch kannst du
die Unsitte vermeiden ein Passwort
mehrfach zu benutzen eine sehr wichtige
Sache denn es kann schon mal passieren
dass ein Passwort irgendwo knackt oder
geliebt wird und dann verliert man den
Überblick was dadurch alles gefährdet
sein könnte aber nordpass geht auch hier
noch einen Schritt weiter und schützt
deine Daten nicht nur passiv sondern
auch proaktiv mit einem ganzen Arsenal
von security features premiums kennt z.B
ist Internet kontinuierlich nach deinen
Daten ab und findet heraus ob diese
nicht möglicherweise gelegt wurden falls
sein sollte wart es dich so dass du
rechtzeitig reagieren und die verbannen
kannst bevor schlimmeres Unglück
hereinbricht darüber hinaus sind die in
nordpass abgelegten Passwörter und
Kreditkartendaten auf all deinen
Endgeräten verfügbar ganz einfach per
Auto fehlt so dass du nicht nur sicherer
fährst sondern auch noch viel Zeit Spaß
und das Beste für die visualpolitik
Community bietet noch fast ein
Sonderangebot bei Abschluss eines 2
Jahres bekommst du einen Monat kostenlos
dazu klicke hierzu einfach auf den
linken
nordpass.com/visualpolitik den ich dir
in die Beschreibung unter diesem Video
packe natürlich kannst du alles in Ruhe
unverbindlich und völlig ohne Risiko
ausprobieren in nordpass kommt mit einer
30-jährigen Geld zurück Garantie was es
sich bis dahin nicht von seinen Vorzügen
überzeugt haben sollte also nichts
besorgt euch nordpassung greift damit
auch gleichzeitig uns finanziell unter
die Arme das könnt ihr übrigens auch
direkt mit Hilfe eines Spenden links den
ich ebenfalls in die Beschreibung
gepackt habe wir sind euch für jede
Unterstützung dann bei den damit hättet
ihr uns euch in Zukunft noch mehr und
noch bessere Videos zu liefern so und
nun ab an den Golf und unsere brennenden
Fragen zu beantworten was ist die kafala
und wie funktioniert sie woher bekommen
diese ihre Arbeitskräfte hat die
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft wirklich dazu
beigetragene Reformen Inka
voranzutreiben wie die FIFA immer
behauptet wie so oft bei komplexen
Themen erleichtert einen Blick in die
Geschichte des Verständnis also sperrt
eure Lauscher auf
[Musik]
die letzte Bastion der Sklaverei
geht auf die Tradition der Beduinen in
den arabischen golfstraßen zurück nach
deren bräuchten übernahmen Gastgeber die
rechtliche und wirtschaftliche
Verantwortung für ausländische Besucher
der Gastgeber wurde ihr Kaffee bedeutet
auf Arabisch Sponsor oder Bürger die
Idee dahinter war dass diese Gastgeber
oder Sponsoren für alle möglichen
Angelegenheiten ihre Gäste
verantwortlich waren sowohl für das Gute
ist auch für das schlechte das heißt
wenn ein Fremder im Lande ankam hat man
dafür gesorgt dass es ihm an nichts
fehlte wenn sich der Gastarbeiter als
Dieb entpuppte musste man als Gastgeber
auch dafür gerade stehen in der Theorie
hört sich das gar nicht so verrückt an
oder dieses
idealsystems änderte sich doch völlig
als kapitalen 1916 zum britischen
Protektorat wurde
das heutige kapverlasssystem ist eine
Mischung aus Einwanderungsgesetzen und
Bräuchen und es ist vor allem eine
Schöpfung des britischen Empire das in
der ersten Hälfte des 20 Jahrhunderts
großen Einfluss am Persischen Golf
ausübte dieses System ermöglicht es den
dritten viele Arbeitskräfte aus
verschiedenen Teilen des Kolonialreichs
in den Nahen und Mittleren Osten zu
holen also auch nach Katar
[Musik]
die Arbeiter kam vor allem aus Südasien
wie euch vorstellen können war das
zurzeit ist besonders nützlich 1971
wurde Katar hat das britische parat los
und ein unabhängiges Land aber man
behielt die alte britische Tradition bei
es sollten einfach weiterhin Leute aus
Indien zum Arbeiten kommen da hat Katar
das System eben beibehalten und ist so
eine Art moderner Sklaverei geformt so
wie wir sie heute kennen daher brauchen
viele Einwanderer die in diesen Ländern
ankommen bis heute einen Kaffee dieser
übernimmt dann die Verantwortung für
ihren rechtlichen Status und je nach
Fall kann es sein dass die Migranten in
allen möglichen Belangen ihres Lebens
von ihren Kaffee abhängig sind
viele Einwanderer die in Ländern mit
kafala-system Arbeiten beklagen sich oft
über ihre Arbeitsbedingungen zum
Beispiel dass ihr Lohn weit unter dem
liege was ihnen versprochen wurde sie
würden gezwungene Monate lang ohne
Bezahlung zu arbeiten es gibt auch
Beschwerden darüber dass die Arbeitgeber
nach jedem Vorwand suchen um einen Teil
des Lohns zu beschlagnahmen zudem gebe
es Marathon Arbeitszeiten und fast keine
Pausen
[Musik]
aber nicht nur das ein Kaffee kann auch
den Reisepass eine Arbeiter
beschlagnahmen man ist also gezwungen im
Land zu bleiben und damit auch gezwungen
zu arbeiten und das ist nun mal ganz
genau Sklaverei dieses Problem betrifft
hauptsächlich ungelernt hat Einwanderer
aus Indien aber es kann auch mal
bekannte Fußball Treffen sei hier beloni
kehrt nach einem 17 monatigen Streit mit
dem katarischen Vereinen alia ich nach
Frankreich zurück in diesem Fall ging es
um den französischen Fußballer hier
belloni der 17 Monate lang in Katar
festgehalten wurde nur internationaler
Druck hat es ihm schließlich ermöglicht
das Land zu verlassen aber leider haben
andere nicht so viel Unterstützung
[Musik]
dieses System ist aber auch aus einem
weiteren Grund extrem perfide früher
nahmen gewöhnliches Sklaven zum Beispiel
auf Feldzügen gefangen oder verschleppte
sie aus dem Heimatland heutzutage im 21
Jahrhundert kommen die Sklaven zunächst
aus freien Stücken zu ihren Ausbeutern
in einigen Ländern hat sich das
mittlerweile herumgesprochen seht euch
mal an was rodrig 2021 sagte als er noch
Präsident der Philippinen war
die hinaus
der Philippino ist noch leben
okay es ist schon fast eine fahrst du
Härte als Verteidiger der Menschenrechte
vorzuführen aber in Bezug auf die kafala
hatte absolut recht
dieses sklavensystem ist bittere
Realität durch die Öl- und Gasvorkommen
und ihren Förderung sind diese leider
unglaublich schnell unglaublich reich
geworden und verlangen immer mehr
Arbeitskräfte es gibt also eine Art
stillschweigenden Sozialpakt schließlich
profitieren dort alle von diesen
Systemen außer natürlich ist Sklaven
wobei die reinen Zahlenverhältnisse in
Katar er für die Ausländer sprechen
müssten es gibt rund 380.000 cataris das
sind die Bürger des Landes die von den
Privilegien das Öl und Gas Reichtums
profitieren insgesamt leben in Katara
aber fast drei Millionen Menschen die
große Mehrheit davon sind keine
katarischen Staatsbürger es handelt sich
um Arbeitsmittel und ihre Anteil wächst
kontinuierlich schaut euch diese Zahlen
für 2022 an
tagesbevölkerung wächst um 13,2% durch
den starken Zuspruch ausländische
Arbeitskräfte da würdet ihr gerne wissen
wie diese Privilegien für die Kataris
aussehen nur ein katalanischer
Staatsbürger braucht nicht einmal zu
arbeiten man hat seine Geschäfte und
seine Investitionen außerdem hilft der
Staat wo er kann es gibt günstig Land
und billige Kredite denn die wirkliche
und harte Arbeit erledigen die
Einwanderer die große Mehrheit von ihnen
kommt aus asiatischen und afrikanischen
Ländern und sie geraten direkt ins
kavala-system und vielleicht stellt ihr
euch mittlerweile auch die Frage wie
schaffen es die cataris immer wieder
neue Arbeitskräfte anzuwerden
schließlich hat sich in den
Herkunftsländer doch mittlerweile
herumgesprochen dass sie dort praktisch
fast klar werden
[Musik]
der arabische Albtraum
ja eine ziemlich gute Frage und wir
werden sie jetzt beantworten lasst uns
für einen Moment nach keraler Reisen
einem Bundesstaat in Indien mit einer
riesigen Bevölkerung dort leben knapp 35
Millionen Menschen und im Durchschnitt
sind diese sehr jung in Kerala gibt es
ein bestimmtes Problem auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt den Mangel an
Arbeitskräften in Gastgewerbe der Grund
der ist 2 Millionen keraliten arbeiten
bereits im Ausland sie arbeiten vor
allem in Katar und anderen arabischen
Ländern dort können Sie rund 1000 $ im
Monat verdienen das ist etwa sechsmal so
viel wie ein ähnlichen Jobs in Kerala
diese Arbeitsmigranten sind bereit viel
Geld an Agenturen zu zahlen damit sie
ihnen in den arabischen Ländern einen
Job und einen Kaffee vermitteln und die
Vermittlungsagenturen langen ordentlich
zu seht euch die folgende Grafik an
[Musik]
die gestrichelte horizontale Linie
markiert den Verdienst eines Monats und
die beiden Stellen die Zahl der
Monatsgehälter da die Wanderarbeiter
anifa Mittler zahlen müssen wie ihr seht
kostet es die Menschen aus Indien
Pakistan oder Bangladesch ein Vermögen
nur um in der arabischen Welt arbeiten
zu können
[Musik]
doch trotz dieser Kosten und Risiken
zieht ist jedes Jahr hunderttausende
dort denn verglichen mit den
Verdienstmöglichkeiten in ihrer Heimat
verdienen sie trotz der hohen Abgaben
ein kleines Vermögen das verdiente Geld
hilft oft der Familie daheim die
Menschen können sich nach ihrer Rückkehr
ein besseres Leben in der Heimat leisten
manche Gründen gab Unternehmen es
handelt sich um einen harten Weg aber es
ist ein Ticket um den Elend in ihren
Herkunftsländern zu entkommen einige
schaffen es sogar in den arabischen
Ländern selbst das Haus zu werden und
sogar Unternehmen zu gründen und diese
Karotte haben nun mal alle Menschen dort
vor der Nase für so etwas wie den
arabischen Traum von Wohlstand begeben
sich Millionen Menschen in ein System
von Menschenrechtsverletzungen sobald
sie sich vermitteln lassen doch nicht
nur die Arbeitsvermittler schlagen aus
dem Profit auch Regierungen tun es
ganz genau Regierungen in Afrika
schicken ihre eigenen Bürger in dieses
sklavensystem ein solcher Fall ist
Uganda die Arbeitsministerin des Landes
Betty ammony erklärt in einem Video was
der Exporte Arbeitskräfte in einem Jahr
so einbringt coffee-export
discountry
59 Millionen Dollars remitte es ist from
externalisation
nämlich 900 Millionen Dollar und bei
einem BIP von rund 40 Milliarden pro
Jahr ist das schon eine hübsche
Einnahmequelle afrikanische
Arbeitskräfte werden in den verfallen
Ländern immer beliebter denn sie bringen
Kostenvorteile für die Arbeitgeber das
auch klingen mag Afrikaner sind bereit
die gleiche Arbeit die Asiaten zu
verrichten aber für weniger Geld allein
im Jahr 2021 haben 85 000
Programm zur Auslagerung von
Arbeitskräften teilgenommen Zielländer
waren Saudi-Arabien Katar und die
Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate und die
ugandische Regierung ist sich sehr wohl
bewusst in was für ein System sie ihre
eigenen Bürger schickt aber es scheint
für sie eine Frage der Prioritäten zu
sein was wiegt mehr Menschenrechte oder
Geld am Ende kann man sich schließlich
alles schön reden mit den riesigen
Verdienst und Aufstiegschancen aber
jetzt wo die Augen der Welt
Öffentlichkeit eine Zeit lang auf
Katalog um die Zustände dort richtet
waren und Fußballmannschaften
protestiert haben hat sich vielleicht
etwas geändert zu Gunsten der
Menschenrechte und genau das nehmen wir
im nächsten Kapitel unter die Lupe
Licht und Schatten in Katars Arbeitswelt
Katar hat schon mehrfach angekündigt das
ist die Bedingung für seine
Beschäftigten verbessern will doch die
Jahre vergingen ohne nennenswerte
Veränderungen trotz zunehmenden
internationalen Drucks der derzeitige
Emir 13 Amt im Jahr 2013 an in seinen
ersten Jahren reformierte er die
Verwaltung des Landes denn oft war
bislang unklar wer in kataren wirklich
die Macht aus die Regierung oder eine
Vielzahl von parallelbehörden
schließlich löste er 2020 die
Premierminister ab und die Veränderungen
begann zu greifen sie her Katar führt
kurz vor der Fußballweltmeisterschaft
Reform und für Mindestlöhne und
Arbeitnehmer eine die Reformen sollen
das Kavala sponsorensystem abschaffen
die Arbeitsgesetze haben sich in Katar
radikal verändert so sehr das ist
richtig gesehen keine Kraft verla mehr
gibt man darf jetzt den Arbeitsplatz
wechseln oder das Land verlassen ohne
die Zustimmung des Arbeitgebers der
früheren Kaffee viel nach offiziellen
Angaben haben seit 2020 bereits von
350.000 Menschen den Job gewechselt ihr
könnt euch sicher vorstellen dass das
durchaus eine große Verbesserung ist
denn wenn die Arbeitnehmer kündigen
können ist das ein Anreiz für den
Arbeitgeber seine Arbeiter anständig zu
behandeln auch eine Mindestlohn wurde
festgesetzt und zwar auf 1000 katarische
real pro Monat was etwa 260 Euro
entsprechend zu diesem Mindestlohn
kommen noch 80 € für Lebensmittel und
130 € für die Unterkunft hinzu sofern
der Arbeitgeber nicht beides zur
Verfügung stellt machen wir uns nichts
vor dieser Mindestlohn ist extrem
niedrig angesetzt Katar ist jedoch das
erste Land am Golf das überhaupt einen
Mindestlohn für alle Arbeitnehmer
beschlossen hat es bleibt aber ein
Problem das System ist uralt es handelt
sich nicht nur einfach um Gesetze Kavala
ist auch eine Kultur und eine solche
ändert sich nicht so schnell
einige Arbeitgeber Zugang noch die neue
Freizügigkeit wirklich zu akzeptieren
sie machen es den Leuten extrem schwer
den Job zu kündigen oder es kommt dazu
Vergeltungsmaßnahmen nach der Kündigung
zum Beispiel sollten Arbeitgeber dafür
dass die ex-arbeiter ihre
Aufenthaltsgenehmigung verlieren indem
man sie als untergetaucht das kann dann
sogar zur Abschiebung ist Herkunft aber
dennoch die Erfahrung schreiten immerhin
in kleinen Schritten voran
eine sehr clevere Änderung in Katar ist
das die Gehälter jetzt per
Banküberweisung bezahlt werden müssen
auch diese Weise können die
Beschäftigten beweisen ob ihr Chef noch
Arbeitslohn schuldet außerdem hat die
katarische Regierung 2019 einen
unterstützungsform für Arbeitnehmer
eingerichtet und Zahlungsausfälle
auszugleichen seitdem hat sie 320
Millionen Dollar ausgezahlt
die Hitze in Katar ist ein
Gesundheitsrisiko für Menschen die
draußen arbeiten müssen und auch hier
gibt es Neuerungen bislang war
dauerhafte Arbeit im Freien von Juni bis
Mitte September verboten jetzt umfasst
das Verbot grundsätzlich die heißesten
fünf Stunden in der Mitte des Tages all
diese Neuerungen wurden in
Zusammenarbeiten mit der Internationalen
Arbeitsorganisation entwickelt das ist
eine Organisation der Vereinten Nationen
die 2018 eine Mission in Katara eröffnet
hat ihr letzter Bericht über das Land
zeigt jedoch ein gemischtes Bild
Katars Arbeiterwohlfahrt Reformen sind
erfolgt aber Herausforderungen bleiben
die IAO erkennt an dass ich die
Bedingungen für tausende Arbeitnehmer
verbessert haben aber sicherstellen dass
die Arbeitsgesetze auch durchgesetzt
werden Menschenrecht aus wie endete
Internet still stimmen dem Zug denn wir
sprechen über das immer gleiche alte
Problem das Gesetz ist die eine Sache
die andere ist seine Durchsetzung denn
egal wie sehr Katar Beton wir haben die
Sklaverei abgeschafft sie dir unsere
Gesellschaft es wird nichts erreicht
wenn es noch an Sanktionen für jede
Mangel die noch immer im Kaff
fallersystem leben hier gibt es noch
eine Menge Raum für Verbesserungen aber
an dieser Stelle ist die Frage wieder an
euch gerichtet glaubt ihr Katar und
andere arabische Länder können dieses
Sklaverei irgendwann vollständig
überwinden erwarten wir vielleicht zu
viel von diesen Ländern wenn wir im
westenreformen anmachen sitzen wir
vielleicht etwas zu hoch auf unserem
moralischen Ausländer trotzdem die
Fußball-WM gucken und mit ihrem
gasheizen wie immer sind auf eure
Diskussion zu diesem Thema schon mächtig
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht
auch dass dabei gelernt habt falls ja
geht uns bitte ein Like das mit meiner
Freundin
keines unserer Videos mehr zu verpassen
testet wird auch unverbindlich das
Angebot unseres heutigen Sponsors
nordpass der für die visualpolitische
Community ein Aktionsangebot bietet
einen Monat kosten oder Nutzung bei
Abschluss eines zweijahres Abos näheres
erfährst du wenn du den linken
nordpass.com special Resort Politik
aufrufst den ich in die Beschreibung
unter diesem Video packe natürlich
freuen uns auch jederzeit über eine
Spende von euch weiterzuführen
Versuche findet ihr ebenfalls in der
Beschreibung unter dem Video macht's gut
und bis bald
[Musik]